and uh our next speaker is a dominic
robin
he actually spent
one year as a postdoc
in berkeley because the people in zurich
suggested that this is a good idea to do
so so he followed our advice and he's
now at stanford university and he talks
about calibrated inference the floor is
yours
thank you so much for can you hear me
well okay yeah thank you so much for the
invitation and the opportunity to speak
here um yeah so this is a joint work
with eugene she's a graduate student at
stanford has done a fantastic job here
yeah before i start um yeah thank you
thank you peter uh you probably most of
you know this location uh i have not
personally worked together with peter
but we spend a lot of time yeah we uh he
was very generous with his time i got a
lot of feedback on my ideas and uh yeah
he he taught me a lot so thank you for
being so generous here um yeah and a lot
of the ideas that you will see here
later are inspired by kind of the ideas
that i got around berkeley from
discussions with bin and peter
all right um
so what are we gonna what are we trying
to do here um starts with a question so
how can we actually uh draw uh
trustworthy conclusions and in
statistics i i would say we have a bunch
of answers to that first one we want to
have relevant data or high quality data
well your assumption should be somewhat
correct
your p values should be valid you don't
want to go on a fishing expedition and
so on and ideally
if you really want to trust a scientific
result you will have independent teams
that can replicate it across well
different teams in different locations
can get to similar conclusions
um at this point we can ask okay are we
missing something here uh
what else what else is there
um and
there's this recent paper
or this recent commentary i would say
nature that i found was very well
formulated where they would say okay uh
repeating experiments is not enough
and well it's an it's a short comment
but they have this picture here where
or here you have like this certain
phenomenon and then you have a bunch of
scientists looking at it from different
angles
um with different
methods of investigation so this is
often called triangulation and they say
well okay if you just try to uh
to repeat an experiment that's not
enough because like if it's just
repeating what people have done before
you might share similar biases or
similar issues that that might have been
in the first study so what they say is
what you should do instead is
you should make strategic use of
multiple approaches to address one
particular question so not just one
approach not just one one type of
experiment but multiple ways of dealing
with a certain question
of course this is not a new idea this
has popped up
many times in the literature here
another article by friedman where he
talks about
uh
how jon snow uh was working on
the cholera
and uh he re it's a very nice example i
won't go into too much detail but
friedman said like what's really nice
about this example is that he's bringing
together many different lines of
evidence so not just one particular data
set not just one methodology but like
many different methodologies that come
to the same
conclusion
okay um now if you want to do this
across multiple data sets of course that
that's perfect but uh maybe also a bit
expensive so the question is kind of can
we already make strategic use of
multiple approaches just on one single
data set
and again there's
there's
some work in the literature here
of course you probably also know about
lemur's paper
where he was complaining that people
often do
make statistical decisions somewhat
randomly so here he says like sometimes
i include certain observations sometimes
i exclude them sometimes i choose the
equation to be linear sometimes i choose
it to be non-linear so like there are a
lot of
design decisions that i can make as a
statisticians that might uh
that might be reasonable
and he says okay the audience now
withholds belief rightfully so until you
can show that your inference is actually
adequately insensitive to your choice of
assumption so if you change your
assumptions a little bit that things
will not change up too much
um yeah more recently also here uh bin
in the audience uh gives us the example
of a biologist who has a lot of modeling
choices
and often there might not be one
particular principle approach just for
one particular choice so then you want
that
the conclusions that you make are
somewhat stable across appropriate
choices okay and here's some concrete
suggestions would we change the way you
pre-process the data change the way you
specify your regressions uh change the
model for the errors and so on
okay so
just talking about what where we are so
far
now you can look at this and start
asking okay well
um
how should we actually choose these
multiple approaches how should we
aggregate this type of things like how
should we report this type of
uncertainty so the the main issue is
that we
usually don't really have a clear
statistical model for this so until we
have a clear statistical mall it's
unclear how to do things optimally and
what distinguishes a good stability
analysis from a bad stability analysis
and from a mathematical perspective the
main challenge here is that
each of your methods might be somewhat
biased for what whatever you want to
study
and you don't really know the structure
and strength of the bias you don't
really know whether they share similar
biases or whether their biases are
completely unrelated so you don't really
know kind of how to aggregate it how to
report it and so on
okay any questions so far
if i take the machine learning point of
view i don't care about this i have a
more than induced predictions i'll check
it how i've heard they are
you know i'm trying to
easy why do we need this if the goal is
prediction
well if you
if you care about whether um
okay so this is not particularly about
predictions it's mostly about parameter
estimation but it's uh
the if if your things are somewhat
stable and your distribution doesn't
change and everything is exactly the
same and you're like in your test as it
is in training then yeah you probably
don't need to worry about these kind of
things but like as soon as there are
some changes
you probably need to worry about uh yeah
quantification of uncertainty and also
about like distributional robustness and
these kind of things and that's also one
reason why i think the machine learning
community has a lot of research in these
areas these days
but this will not like this i don't
think this talk was satisfying machine
learners this is for statisticians
all right um so yeah
high level we want to have a model for
what's happening here um so
i'll come back to that whole
making use of different approaches and
now just talk about
the model here so what i want to
formalize is the notion of
distributional uncertainty you can ask
hey what does it mean so my the idea is
here similar to the robustness
literature there is a there's a target
distribution p naught that you want to
make a statement about so maybe that's
the population of the united states
but then when you set up your data
collection procedures there are all
kinds of like mistakes that creep in
right so there might be certain
contaminations of the data there might
be some confounding that you might not
be able to
control for some sampling bias it might
be batch effects so all kinds of
distribution shifts and changes between
the population that you care about and
the population that you actually sample
from
now in statistics we have a ton of uh
methods to deal with known structures so
for example you can do re-weighting if
you know kind of how
like the type of
bias that you got but what we want to
deal with now is
uh is what if
you actually have unknown perturbation
so let's say you do your re-weighting
and say okay i hope i control for
everything but what if something is
still wrong how can you quantify
kind of the unknown non-adversarial
perturbations that you will not be able
to deal with with these fancy
statistical techniques
and this is very high level so i'll go
into more detail
now in a second as a running example
let's just deal with linear regression
so we're interested in a linear
regression parameter of
uh the the unpredictable distribution
but now uh you don't observe iid data
from the distribution that you care
about but from a perturbed distribution
pxi
and you get your estimator and now you
can decompose the uncertainty into two
components
so this is your estimate this is the
thing that you want to estimate you get
an error due to sampling that's what we
usually try to
quantify in statistical inference and
then there's also this arrow due to the
distribution of perturbation right
and we're going to put a little bit more
structure on that in a second
any questions so far
okay so
without any additional structure here
you kind of lost obviously right so you
can look to how have people dealt with
this in the past and often what people
do is they put a kind of a bound on this
based on background knowledge so for
example in causal inference we have
sensitivity analysis where you say like
oh i think my confounder is at most this
strong so then you derive bounce on that
thing and then you can
integrate that or uh yeah in the
robustness literature maybe you know
kind of
like which percentage of your population
uh can be contaminated and then again
you can
actually design estimators here for
which you can bound this this arrow here
um
but that is uh somewhat adversarial
right you look at worst case bounds um
so what we want to do now is instead we
just say like okay maybe nature is not
adversarial and will not mess with us
like in the worst case way
in which case maybe the distributional
perturbations here are just random
maybe this arrow here
maybe the difference between those two
things is just random somehow right
okay how can we deal with this
any questions so far
all righty so what are we trying to do
we want to construct a confidence
interval that
covers the unperturbed parameter
um and as i said before
sensitivity analysis and
other procedures they often rely on user
knowledge so you need to input how
how far you think those two things are
we will not do that we will try to get
it through a different version we will
connect it to the idea before where you
say like okay you have multiple
estimation strategies for one particular
thing that you're interested in and
we're going to use that to estimate the
strength of the perturbations on a very
high level
i'll make that more precise in a second
related literature i already mentioned
most of that so i'll skip that just
saying like the classic robustness
literature and modern robustness
literature is
is related to this but they usually look
at worst case bounds
in causal inference people often look at
differently specified regressions uh
yeah as i said for example lemur has
been recommended in this video of course
also
okay so if we want to do this the math
here first we have to choose an
asymptotic regime right so of course you
can choose an asymptotic regime where
this is larger than this in which case
you can just ignore this and do a
statistical inference as usual
what we did was we chose
we chose a regime where those two things
are of the same order and the reason for
that is that we want to we want to
design our uncertainty measure to be an
extension of current practice and
current practice then of course you want
this to be relevant that's why we chose
it kind of of the same order but of
course you could also say like what
happens i want to
i want to do uncertainty quantification
where this is large and this is small
but that's maybe a topic for another
talk
okay so let's get to the meat here so
what is the most i said we want to have
the the distributional perturbation
somewhat random so you can ask okay what
is the most generic most natural
distribution of perturbation
that you can write down
maybe you have your own answer to this
but for me at least we said like okay
what happens if i just take a particular
event and i just randomly give it a
slightly higher or slightly lower
probability than in the in the original
distribution right
so um
math incoming so in a very simple case
here i have a discrete distribution with
weights one over m
and uh now i'm just drawing some random
weights
psi case and now each event
gets randomly upgraded or down weighted
compared to the
to the to the population of interest and
then i draw from that perturb
distribution
and then if you do like a tiny bit of
math two or three lines what you're
going to see is if if you look
marginally at the
at the at the variation um
what you're going to get is the variance
that you usually expect under iid
sampling times a global scaling factor
that depends on the strength of your
distributional perturbation
so if there is no variance in your size
then this thing here will be zero but as
if you like amp this up then
marginally you will get a huge
adjustment factor here and the
interesting thing here is that
no matter which
side you uh you you choose here you
always get the same scaling factor so
this thing just blows up the variance of
each empirical process that you look and
by by this scaling factor that depends
on the unknown distribution of
perturbation that you don't know
okay any questions
yes
don't you need to decide to be
differentiable or something
no just id um here at this point i'm
just looking at this discrete measures
this is not for continuous distributions
we have a similar version [ __ ]
continuous distributions in our
now paper so psi can be can be can be
anything it should be like non-negative
and then
any other questions
just to sum it up what we did is we have
two stage sampling procedures first to
mess up the distribution like by
randomly upgrading and downgrading
events
and then marginally when you look at the
empirical processes the variance is
blown up by a constant factor that you
don't know
you'd mean the expectation of psi
oh you could also take the expectation
of this thing uh the expectation of this
inner thing is still zero so you can
show that like marginally your thing is
still unbiased
uh yes there should be more computers so
marginally this whole thing is still
unbiased
but your variances are blown up
so so that that is kind of a funny thing
that happens here so all the estimators
that we used under iad sampling are
still good estimated on this because you
still have marginally unbiased
estimators of of the loss and so on the
only thing that will change is your
uncertainty quantification
does it make sense
all right
okay so something that i will that is
actually slightly stronger here is we're
going to assume that your data is so
motivated by what we've just seen is
that we assume that our data
follows roughly a gaussian distribution
where you have the variance as usual
then times the scaling factor delta
squared that you that you don't know
so this is a simplified version um
because of the particular asymptotic
regime that we have to look at in our
paper you actually have to choose a
triangular
array of of data sets to kind of make
this statistically like super precise
but
the way you can just think about it is
like you just sample from a distribution
and then
you have a gaussian distribution with a
scaling factor here
and just like as a reminder here if you
forget all the story that i've told you
so far
if you just draw id from p naught
this is a standard statistical inference
it's just a special case here with delta
equal one right
so you can just think about this as so
far as just like uh
yeah weakening the assumptions that we
usually make with iid sampling
yes
okay so yeah first question is when does
this assumption hold i already kind of
gave you some little results uh the
distribution perturbation model here you
can actually show that you don't just
get the variances scaled by a factor but
actually that you still get asymptotic
normality under the right scaling and
there are a bunch of other kind of cases
where you get the scaling factor in the
variance so for example if you sample
clusters of units where units in a
cluster are like very close to each
other
and the classes themselves are drawn
independently and you don't know their
membership then you also get this
unknown scaling factor in the variance
that we just that we just talked about
okay
now what we often get is and people are
like okay i could have written down
something else and i would have gotten
some
and i would have gotten a different
behavior
so we looked into that a little bit and
what you actually can show is on a
symmetry assumption on your
distributional perturbations you will
always get this global scaling factor
delta
so the one that we just discussed before
and again this is a little bit of math
here
and the symmetry assumption here just
states if two events have the same
probability under the original
distribution then the perturbation
strength that they will get will be the
same i'm not saying that they both get
the same perturbation i'm just saying
that they
exhibit the both the same perturbation
strength so what that kind of indicates
here is a is a random perturbation so
you can't just take one particular event
that has small probability and then make
it suddenly have probability one
um
that would be an adversarial
perturbation but you want uh random
perturbations and you can uh you can
formalize it like that
okay yeah and then you say like um so
that's the main symmetry assumption then
you can show that for all size you will
have this uh global scaling factor in
the variance for uh empirical processes
okay
you can also relate it to other
statistical concepts
so
for example sampling bias or random
confounding you can show that we had
that scaling factor delta if your delta
is very large and you write down a
causal model you will get a lot of
confounding if your delta is small you
will have little confounding so
the the distributional perturbation
model will mess up will mess things up
and include like these
issues that we often worry about in
statistics separately
okay and just to show you like one
little thing here which is the violation
of the iid assumptions
um so if we draw from this two-stage
model and the data is iid from the
perturb distribution if you look at the
marginal correlation you will also get a
global correlation between cdi and ij
which will always be a constant
delta squared
so somehow what the random perturbation
model does is you can think about this
as just creating observations that are
marginally correlated
uh and they're all correlated with the
same with the same data no matter what
transformations of the data you choose
okay any questions
yes so how does sigma squared play a
role in this result
um
oh yeah i'm sorry that it was an
original
i i wrote it for with covariances and
then you have supermassive word here um
yeah sorry that was just i did not fix
it yet
you can just delete that
questions
all right um inference yeah that is the
interesting part now um
first how not to do inference um so if
you use standard variance formulas you
will of course underestimate the
uncertainty
because of the fact that
you will only kind of cover
the perturbed parameter and not the
original parameter you can make that
precise with math but i don't have
enough time i'll i'll move on that so it
and you can actually show that it's
impossible without additional
assumptions to get to the delta
so what we're gonna do now
is uh
we're gonna put down additional
assumptions now we're coming back to the
original idea that you don't just have
one estimators but you have multiple
estimation strategies
so yeah you have a bunch of estimators
had theta k that you believe estimate a
very similar quantity
and the first assumption that we need to
put down is that they're asymptotically
linear
that is usually relatively easy to prove
for m estimators under iid sampling
under our two-stage assumption you have
to show that again and we have some
arguments in our paper why this thing
here is still relatively simple in in
low dimensional scenarios
the more crucial assumption is what
peter mentioned earlier is that you now
have a bunch of estimators here and
we're going to assume that all of these
estimators if you had infinite data from
the unperturbed distribution that those
would actually all estimate the same
thing
so you need some scientific background
knowledge to not just come on up with
one estimator but potentially two three
four five different estimators that if
you had infinite data from the
unperturbed distribution estimate the
right thing
um
we are robust if you if you don't if
this assumption is not true but i'll
come to that later
okay any questions so far
but they're all estimated on the same on
one data set but what you want is like
in theory if you have infinite data from
the uncertain distribution that they
would all agree
so there's like yeah one average
treatment effect and you have a bunch of
different ways to estimate it for
example
yeah and one way kind of one example
that we often have in mind is that it
calls inference maybe you have not just
one adjustment set that you can use in
observational data but you have a bunch
of different adjustment sets that each
equally make sense to you so you
immediately have not just one estimator
but like
five or maybe seven
okay so how do we actually do inference
i'll go through that relatively quickly
because i don't have that much time um
so what you do is you look at the
difference between two estimators you
square it and now if you look at our
asymptotic thing you're going to see
like oh this is now gaussian
distribution
if you take it to this square you
actually get a chi-squared distributed
random variable with the variance of the
differences of the influence functions
times the scaling factor delta squared
so what you can do now is you can try to
you can try to estimate this and then
you'll get a very noisy estimate of
delta squared you do that for a bunch of
estimation strategies
and
you do that for a bunch of estimation
strategies and then you can form an
estimate of the perturbation strength by
looking at between estimator variation
divided by the expected variation
assuming id sampling
okay
very high level so one thing that is
important here to note is it's not just
about the between estimator variation it
is about the
relative stability it's not about
absolute stability it's about relative
stability and one reason why this makes
sense intuitively
is uh there's this quote by wittenstein
a philosopher
telling the story of someone who says
like oh i bought several copies of a
newspaper to assure myself that whatever
was written in newspaper is true if you
if you use 10 times a very similar
estimator that is not an indication that
your result is trustworthy so it's not
the absolute stability the absolute
estimated variation it counts it's the
relative variation that counts compared
to how different you expect them to be
so that's an important lesson here
okay yeah and then like with some theory
you can build what we call eugen
intervals eugene was the student who
worked on this
so
i things work as usual you have your
estimate theta you have your
normal quantiles your variance estimate
as usual but now you have this
adjustment factor delta hat that you
need to like blow up uh your your
confidence intervals for the
distributional uncertainty and the the
probability here now is over both the
sampling uncertainty and the
distributional uncertainty so what
you're really covering here is the
parameter that you want to cover and not
the parameter
okay any questions
yes so how how strong is the assumption
of weakly coordinated estimators uh
would for example i use m estimator with
different loss function with that count
um what you can do then in a
pre-processing step is you can
de-correlate them we describe it in our
paper so you can you can do a linear
transformation of your after estimators
to kind of again form independent ones
but if they're extremely highly
correlated then your estimate of delta
hat will be very unstable and you'll
you'll see that
and that is that is probably an
indication that you should
go back to your scientific knowledge and
think whether you come up and come up
with estimation strategies that are less
correlated than the ones that you
currently look at
yeah
but that's following up but this is
discovered in your assumptions one two
and three i mean you can
you assume implicitly that they're
sufficiently different right otherwise
yes so if all of them have the same
exactly the same influence function then
you're screwed and you can't estimate
that but then
but as as long as they have different
influence functions asymptotically
you can you can do things so you need an
assumption for something somehow right i
think you have not oh yes
yes there is a there's a part that i
mean
yes i need those five hits to
[Music]
any other questions
yes
maybe it's way beyond but
you you assume essentially parametric
setting or a low dimensional setting
right so what happens in a
non-parliamentary or high dimensional
settings
um so i think a similar
thing still goes through for let's say
yeah the sparsified lasso and so on but
once you're just dealing with something
like with uh
uh yeah l1 consistent estimation high
dimensional setting i yeah
i i don't have any anything for that so
you need to be in a semi-parametric set
rates that's what we're done with here
okay um
how much time do you actually have okay
okay so
let me just quickly go through a
numerical example here um
so i
we draw from this causal graph you want
to estimate the causal effect of x1 on y
now we have both sampling and
distribution uncertainty here
now if you if you believe that this
graph is true you find a bunch of
estimators there's not just one there's
like three or four
no probably six or seven
and um
now
first what we tried to estimate was uh
was delta and we
we looked at two different things first
when all your
estimators actually estimate the correct
thing in which case you get a pretty
good estimate of the underlying delta
but there's a lot of vari there is a you
get more conservative if one of your
adjustments that is actually wrong so we
added
one estimate where you actually forget
to adjust for a confounding variable
just to see like how our method performs
and like theoretically you can show that
you usually get over coverage and that's
also what happens here in the simulation
um
so now here the the red or yeah the red
dots here are kind of coverage with
confidence intervals that are computed
as usual and then the green dots are our
kind of adjusted ones and what you see
is that uh coverage is much much closer
to 0.95 what you're actually interested
in here so here the takeaway is
obviously that if you don't calibrate
your confidence intervals then you get
over under coverage because you will uh
not estimate the distributional
uncertainty
okay i'll skip this part and
go to a bunch of high level remarks here
um
so yes what we sometimes get is that
people say okay well this makes very
strong assumptions and we agree these
are strong assumptions that you assume
that nature is not adversarial and just
randomly messes with your distribution
right
um but also it is weaker than just
assuming that the data is iid and just
running with that right so in some way
we're just weakening kind of
what is usually done in the most common
inferential strategy in statistics
uh you can also generalize it um
that that
that the perturbation that acts on x is
different that the perturbation that
acts on the epsilon so you can do a
component-wise distributional
uncertainty model but i'll i'll skip the
details for that what we often get from
practitioners is that they say like oh
okay i'm scared that my confidence
intervals will blow up and just be like
super large and
yeah obviously you don't want that
in our application it was actually
reasonable so sometimes we get
confidence intervals that are twice as
large sometimes we get confidence
intervals that are similarly large so at
least in the application that we looked
at it was not completely unreasonable in
terms of the final
confidence levels that we got
and of course but still theoretically it
can happen that these confidence
intervals will be quite large
and
well maybe if your assumptions are
actually correct then that just is a is
an indication that the distribution
uncertainty is of higher order than the
sampling uncertainty so what that means
in some sense is maybe that
the the statistical
that this is the standard statistical
confidence interval is actually not very
meaningful because another type of
uncertainty is of higher order than what
you just computed right so maybe that is
also good warning that you just like
okay that you have to step back and say
okay are my standard confidence
intervals actually actually uh something
meaningful here
i'm
gonna
skip that also gonna skip the looking
ahead i just wanted to say that we have
a
package
for getting started um
what was important to us because i think
it is not entirely clear directly how do
you actually sample from a
distributional uncertainty model so we
wanted to create a package where it's as
simple as an arches running these two
lines to
get
get a get data
what you have to tell are is that the
distributional uncertainty model will
induce correlations between x and y
so
you need to tell
r that
both x and y are drawn from the same
distribution in some way so the way we
set it up here is we generate
what we call a distributional seed and
the way it works you just choose your
sample size and also the distributional
perturbation that you're aiming for
and so you get your distributional seed
and then you can just draw a gaussian
distribution
and
like draw from a multivariate perturbed
distribution uncertain distributional
uncertainty model
yeah just to give you one example how
this looks like so both on the left and
on the right hand side you see the q q
plot of 1000 observations
here just like a standard gaussian
distribution and here a perturbed
distribution
with a delta equals five
uh uniform
a random variable and so on so
we also have functions for actually
doing calibrated inference um
we call it
column for calibrated linear models so
you put in the formulas that you believe
estimate the same thing you put in the
data you put in your target
you get p values and standard errors
okay so yeah to just sum up
the tool sets here we have a bunch of so
you can just generate from the
distribution uncertainty model gaussian
distribution uniform binomial chi
squared and so on what you usually would
want to do and we also have a bunch of
kind of tools to do calibrated inference
in linear models and calibrated
inference and generalized linear models
yeah
it's not very hard to implement each of
those things are you can do in a bunch
of lines but i believe it's easier to
get started if those things are
are available
okay i have more philosophical remarks
if i have time left
okay
so what are we trying to do here
um
yeah so usually people think about
statistics as dealing with sampling
uncertainty what we're trying to do is
like extend the uncertainty notion here
and i try to make a case for and more
details in the paper that under a
distribution uncertainty model you have
certain types of confounding you will
have correlated data and you will also
have selection bias so we're kind of
extending kind of the uncertainty notion
here a little bit this is not like not
an inclusion so if your confounding is
really adversarial you should not use
our method right or if your selection
bias is really adversarial don't use our
method
it's more like if you believe if you
don't think nature is adversarial and
more like random then this is the right
way maybe of
thinking about it
okay one
more philosophical comment here is
um often in statistics if n goes to
infinity we get uncertainty that goes to
zero
right so you might get confidence
intervals with a length of 10 to the
power of minus 4 and 10 to the power of
-6
and you can think about this two ways
you first say like oh my uncertainty is
almost zero or the other thing you ask
like am i actually measuring the right
thing here um am i actually capturing
uncertainty here
so what happens in our model if n goes
to infinity
you can show that
if the estimators are uncorrelated
otherwise you have to do transformations
you can show that the overall variance
estimate converges to a weighted
between
theta k's
variants so these are the theta case if
you had infinite data from the
unperturbed distribution if the
assumption that i put down before is
correct and this thing here is zero
and your uncertainty estimate really
goes to zero now if for some reason
asymptotically your estimators don't
agree
then this will always be bounded away
from zero and your uncertainty estimate
will never go to zero
so
from a high level i believe that makes
sense
because what that just means if if
you're almost if your assumptions are
almost correct you will get very precise
inference so your
your your variance estimate will go to
zero but if your assumptions are grossly
violated so if your things are actually
estimating different things
you will have high uncertainty no matter
how large n is
and in some way kind of you think can
think about of your assumptions i think
looking through a microscope if your
assumptions are bad you will always have
uh
wide in like wide intervals but if your
assumptions are good then
then your intervals will all get smaller
and smaller
okay any questions about this remark
or anything else
all right
um
one last comment sorry to bother you
here with the the whole philosophical
stuff the reason that philosophy here i
believe is a bit more important or just
these high level thoughts is that i
don't think that constructing these type
of
uncertainty measures is really a
mathematical problem i think it's more
of a design problem where you want to
design something that is as intuitive
and as close to kind of what people kind
of
like intuitively want to do but also how
they want to kind of the way they want
to have the output close to something
that they can interpret so that's why i
spend a lot of time on this because i
want to construct something that is very
close and very intuitive um
to
[Music]
people um so
we we had the
chassis uh talk before we ask like what
is the third number so we we somehow
have this consensus and statistics that
there is an estimate and then there's a
standard error and then kind of up like
the opinions diverge on kind of what we
should like report next right what is
the what is the next thing that we
should report and i can see at least
like three versions of the of the future
in 20 years right the first thing is
that we just said okay maybe in 20 years
people will still do things the way they
do them now they'll compute the
confidence intervals or p values the
same way
for the most basic tools
then there's maybe a more optimistic
view where we say like okay there will
be a lot of other numbers where we kind
of issue such things such as like
stability on the distribution shift
sensitivity to outliers method stability
and so on so for all the kinds of things
that can go wrong in statistical
analysis we'll have a bunch of other
numbers so people don't just look at
those two numbers but they look a lot at
a lot of other numbers
right and now there's this thing in
between
where you say like okay well
the other alternative is actually to try
to integrate other types of uncertainty
into our current variance estimates so
here the answer would be
we won't do a third number but we will
choose
we will change the meaning of the second
number and try to account for more than
what people currently uh account for if
that makes sense
uh as bloody so i i really hope that
like
we're gonna do more because i'm still a
bit hesitant we can capture everything
in one number but uh i i also like uh
binary decision making and the
simplicity of just having one number um
so
yeah that's what was the reason for
doing this project
okay um yeah just to wrap up quickly
what did we do here um we built
essentially theoretical guarantees for a
version of a stability analysis that a
lot of people already do or advocate for
um
what we get in the end are p values and
confidence intervals so what i believe
is relatively easy to interpret for
people
doing practical work it's very the
output will be similar to what they are
used to working with
as i mentioned briefly it can expand it
to more complex perturbations so that
the perturbations that acts on your
coverage space x might be different than
the ones that act on
the the
the arrows for example
um there are two issues that you might
encounter in practice so the first one
is potentially large confidence
intervals we haven't seen that on our
real world data set but i i could
imagine that it happens and as i said
before that could be an indication that
your distribution uncertainty really is
kind of of higher order or maybe your
assumptions are completely off
and the other thing is it could be
potentially be unstable right as i said
before 10 times the same newspaper will
not help you here so 10 times a very
similar estimate might just relate to a
very unstable estimate of delta so this
really encourages people to think hard i
hope
i hope it encourages people to think
hard about how can they come up with
different estimation strategies for
their particular research question
yeah then that's it thank you for your
attention papers and archive
[Applause]
thank you very much for the nice
presentation we already had
quite a few questions but uh i still
give time for
one or two big
we're very happy to see that a lot of
our discussion now become mathematicized
and you have formal results and so one
comment i have under absolute stability
i actually think that we also need
absolute stability the relative
stability is really the idea has already
embedded all the testing like t and all
of that right so that's i think
corresponding to two numbers is both
actually the absolute
effect size and also the relative which
is uh the ratio of the two but the two
dimensions are both embedded in the
absolute and also relative stability yes
yeah i i agree i like for for our first
mathematically that's what came out i i
still think yeah you should probably
also report the absolute thing if you
only report the absolute thing i would
just avoid that people are incentivized
to just do like super tiny perturbations
to their model and then claim that
things are stable so
yeah you probably need both to kind of
really prevent people from
yeah
messing with things here
just um
a practical question about the
in-between option
so um now what my medical collaborators
usually say is that all you do is you
come in you change what we've done the
errors get
we lose results
um right you have to and when you have
so many
options for what to incorporate you know
you could incorporate distributional
assumptions you know all these things
how will you actually convince them what
are the things that they really have to
account for because you know from their
point of view we'll always add sources
of uncertainties the errors will get
bigger
great point i thought about this a lot
so the way we
so there are two things here actually so
so the first one is um
the intervals might get bigger because
again you know you account for
distributional uncertainty but also now
you believe that those five models are
correct right so you can do inverse
variance waiting between them you might
still and this is a tricky point in
standard statistical inference you
usually can't always do inverse variance
waiting because you might actually test
and see that those two things estimate
different things so inverse variance
weighting will not be justified in a
classical statistical setting but in our
setting
it is
it is actually justified if you believe
in the distribution uncertainty model so
our confidence intervals if you do that
on top of that can actually get smaller
also and now what you report is now the
average a weighted average of all of
your kind of estimation strategies which
i believe is maybe better things to do
just like randomly choosing one of them
and yeah so
so there is an interesting aspect that
you can actually get smaller confidence
interval for that so that was yeah that
i i knew that like if you always get
larger confidence intervals like people
will just be like no sorry i'm out of
here but uh
yeah so there is a there is a way to
actually
be better now yeah
okay so in due of time i think uh we
close uh the session here let's thank
both speakers again
[Applause]
and